this video we're going to try to get a
sense of what the limit as x approaches
3 of x to the third minus 3x squared
over 5x minus 15 is
and when i say get a sense we're going
to do that by
seeing what values for this expression
we get as x gets closer and closer to 3.
now one thing that you might want to try
out is well what happens to this
expression when x is equal to 3 well
then it's going to be 3 to the third
power minus three times three squared
over five times three
minus fifteen so at x equals three this
expression is going to be and see the
numerator of 27 minus 27 0
over 15 minus 15 over 0. so this
expression is actually not defined at x
equals 3. we get this indeterminate form
we get 0 over 0. but let's see even
though the function even though the
expression is not defined let's see if
we can get a sense of what the limit
might be
and to do that i'm going to set up a
table
so let me
set up a table here
and actually i'm going to set up two
tables
so this is x
and this is
x to the third
minus 3 x squared
over
5 x
minus 15. and actually i'm going to do
that again and i'll tell you why in a
second
so this is going to be x and this is
x to the third minus 3 x squared
over 5 x minus 15.
the reason why i set up two tables i
didn't have to do two tables i could
have done it all in one table but
hopefully this will make it a little bit
more intuitive what i'm trying to do
is on this left table i'm going to let's
try out x values that get closer and
closer to 3 from the left from values
that are less than 3 so for example we
go to 2.9 and figure out what the
expression equals when x is 2.9 but then
we can try to get even a little bit
closer than that we could go to
2.99 and then we could go even closer
than that we could go to 2.999
and so one way to think about it here is
as we try to figure out what this
expression equals as we get closer and
closer to 3 we're trying to approximate
the limit from the left so limit
from
the left
and why do i say the left well if you
think about this on a coordinate plane
these are the x values that are to the
left of three but we're getting closer
and closer and closer we're moving to
the right but these are the x values
that are on the left side of 3 they're
less than 3. but we also in order for
the limit to exist we have to be
approaching the same thing from both
sides from both the left and the right
so we could also try to approximate the
limit
from
the right
and so what values would those be well
those would be those would be x values
larger than 3. so we could say 3.1 but
then we might want to get a little bit
closer we could go 3.01 but then we
might want to get even closer to 3.
3.001 and every time we get closer and
closer to 3 we're going to get a better
approximation for or we're going to get
a better sense of what we are actually
approaching
so let's get a calculator out and do
this and you could keep going 2.99999999
3.0001
now one key idea here to point out
before i even calculate what these are
going to be sometimes when people say
the limit from both sides or the limit
from the left or the limit from the
right they imagine that the limit from
the left is negative values and the
limit from the right are positive values
but as you can see here the limit from
the left are to the left of the x value
that you're trying to find the limit at
so these aren't negative values these
are just approaching the 3 right over
here from values less than 3. this is
approaching the 3 from values larger
than 3.
so let's see let's calculate
the value of this expression when x is
equal to 2.9
[Music]
so we have 2.9
to the third power
minus
3 times
2.9
[Music]
squared
which is
close the parentheses
so that's our numerator and then divided
by open parenthesis
5 times 2.9
minus 15 that's our denominator is equal
to let's see i got about 1.682
1.682
so now let's keep going
so
let's see if we do 2.99
to the third power
minus
3 times
2.99
squared
is equal to
and then we divide that by
our denominator open open parenthesis 5
times 2.99
minus 15
is equal to
1.78802
well i'll just round that to 1.788
approximately 1.788
and now let's get even closer to 3.
remember we're now approaching 3 from
the left so 2.999 is even that much
closer to 3. so let's get the calculator
out again
and
we get
now we get 2.999
to the third power
minus 3 times open parentheses 2.999
squared
close parentheses so that's our
numerator
divided by
open parenthesis
5 times 2.999
minus 15
is equal to
1.7988 or approximately 1.7988
approximately 1.7988
so it seems to be getting closer and
closer to 1.8
and you could even verify try
2.9999 see if it's getting closer to 1.8
so this is our limit from the left now
we could try the limit from the right so
what happens when we
try 3.1
so 3.1
to the third power
minus three
times open parenthesis
3.1
squared close parentheses
that's our numerator divided by
open parenthesis 5 times 3.1
minus 15 that's our denominator is equal
to 1.922
1.922
all right let's keep going this this is
something strangely fun about this
all right
so let's see when x is 3.01 so now we're
approaching we're approaching x equals
three from the right from values that
are larger we're getting closer and
closer and closer we're approaching from
the right but we're moving towards the
left two words x equals three without
equaling x equals three so let's do
three point zero one
to third power
minus three times open parenthesis
3.01
squared
close parentheses that's our numerator
divided by open parenthesis 5 times 3.01
minus 15
close parentheses is equal to
1.81 i'll say roughly 1.812
approximately 1.812
it does look like we're approaching 1.8
from above now but let's just get even
closer 3.001
so
we can finish at least what i've put on
our tables here if you're unsure you can
just keep getting closer and closer and
closer
3.00001 if you're interested let's just
do this one 3.001
to the third power minus 3 times
3.001
squared
close parentheses that's our numerator
divided by open parenthesis 5 times
3.001
minus 15
that's our denominator is equal to
roughly 1.801
so approximately 1.801
so based on what we're seeing here i
would make the estimate that this looks
like it's approaching 1.8
so is this equal to 1.8 as i said
in the future we're going to be able to
find this out exactly but if you're not
sure about this you could try even
closer and closer and closer values
actually just for kicks let's just do a
super close value let's let's try it
let's do 2.1
let's let's see what that gets us so
we're getting really cool we're
approaching from the left but we're
getting really close to three now
so let me get the calculator out here
okay so how many is that that is five
nines so two point one two three four
five
to the third power
minus three times
and we're gonna have have 2.12345
squared close parentheses
that's our numerator divided by
5 times 2.123
2.99999
minus 15
that's our denominator is equal to
notice we got even closer in fact if we
round this at all this is going to be
1.8
so if we round it to the nearest
thousandths this is going to oh
yeah if we round this to the nearest
thousandths is going to be 1.8 so we're
getting very close here to 1.8 and if
you're not feeling good about that you
could go even closer and closer and
closer to three to feel better and
better and better about it once again
we're approximately we're seeing what is
the behavior as we get closer and closer
three from the left and from the right
and not only is this valuable for
calculating limits and sometimes you
would have to calculate them numerically
like this
but it also gives you an intuition for
what a limit is all about